let's go beyond the legendary fortnight
skins here are some of the rarest
fortnight skins around the Reaper the
Reaper is the crown jewel of season
threes hired gun set which just so
happened to resemble Keanu Reeves his
character John wick the infamous
assassin with a soft spot for puppies
the season 3 battle pass announcement
came complete with the Reaper skin
jumping from an explosion machine gun in
hand yeah I'm taking on back recon
expert when battle royale debuted
players didn't appreciate all the skins
that were available one such example
from season 1 is possibly the rarest in
the game the recon expert outwardly
she's not too interesting and didn't
seem worth the initial 1,200 V bucks
cost but her rarity is directly
connected to the lackluster look since
no one bought the skin before it
disappeared from the shop aerial assault
trooper another season 1 throwback the
aerial assault trooper was one of the
first skins available in battle royale
so only players who first joined the
game's hypetrain had access to it again
players missed out on the aerial assault
trooper because of its lack of flash
despite not being one of the most
exciting skins this one definitely has
the power of nostalgia behind it
renegade Raider renegade Raider is also
from fortnight's first season but this
one has a little Moxie after achieving
level 20 players could purchase this
outfit in the seasonal shop and were
probably drawn to her post-apocalyptic
look just as the Reaper resembles John
wick renegade Raider recalls another
movie character Tank Girl keep your eye
out if epic decides to make this
available for late comers to add to
their wardrobes Mary Marauder Mary
Marauder and his frowny-face gingerbread
mask came with The Merry Christmas set
these skins were only available for a
limited time and while the merry
Marauder didn't have the same fanatic
following that the Halloween skins did
if you didn't grab them at the time
you'll never get to wear them unless
epoch brings them back in the future to
spread some Christmas fear Black Knight
the Black Knight is the glowing eyed
scourge of the wailing woods that was
released as a part of the for tonight
set back in season 2 a just reward for
those who achieved max level players
coveted for the reputation points that
signifies and despite the red nights
later availability in the shop those who
worked hard to get the Black Knight skin
still remained the only players who've
earned the exclusive right to wear the
armor of the
darkest of the fortnight's the galaxy
galaxy is probably the most literally
expensive fortnight skin exclusive to
the owners of the six hundred and fifty
dollar Samsung Galaxy Tab s4 or the one
thousand dollar galaxy note nine phone
the galaxy skin was announced ahead of
the fortnight Android beta and quickly
became a fan fave ragnarok skin if you
really want to be the Viking of
fortnight you'll probably have found
some way to get the Ragnarok scan during
season five only available to players
skilled enough to kill their way up to
tier 100 that season Ragnarok is the
mark of a dedicated player and testament
to how Epic Games likes to treat its
best and most brutal battle royale
players suffice it to say it Brad no
rocks
[Applause]